in four days alright avenges time to
live up to your name be the first to
experience the end let's give them
something to remember Avengers and game
with a pg-13 everywhere Friday how's it
going everybody it's Warren and a few
hours ago Marvel Studios released a
brand new official TV spot for Avengers
endgame and as you just saw there's not
too much new footage in this TV spot but
there is some new dialogue so I'll be
breaking that down in this video and
also if you're new to my channel be sure
to subscribe to stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers in game
and so you can enter my life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway I'll talk
more about that at the end so the first
scene with rocket talking to the
Avengers is kind of new the dialogue is
new and a brief clip is new but for the
most part we've seen this clip before
but rocket says to the Avengers
alright Avengers time to live up to your
name this seems to be right before the
heroes decide to go into space try to
find and fight Thanos and once they find
in fight Thanos they'll defeat him use
the Infinity Gauntlet to bring everybody
back and therefore avenge everybody that
has fallen so that's what rocket is
talking about but this falls back into
what Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios said he said that Avengers in
game is very much going to be about the
original six Avengers actually avenging
people that's what this movie is about
the avengers trying to bring back
everybody who is victim to the snap
avenging their friends their families
and the entire universe and it seems
like they make this very clear very
early on in the movie and then we have
the next new line by Tony Stark let's
give him something to remember this is
most likely from the first 15 to 20
minutes of the movie if we go by what
President Kevin Feige has said saying
that the material and the trailers are
most likely only from the first 15 to 20
minutes and this is most likely not from
when the Avengers go and fight Thanos
for the very first time in Avengers
endgame because this is coming from Tony
Stark and based off of everything that
we know Tony Stark does not go with the
Avengers originally when they fight
Thanos for the first time again in
Avengers endgame we know that Fanus will
most likely attack the Avengers compound
so this could be from that we know that
Tony Stark has his brand new mark 85
Iron Man's suit in Avengers
game and it definitely has some weapon
upgrades so it seems like when Tony
Stark got back to earth and recovered he
definitely had some time to think about
what he needed to defeat Thanos in his
rematch and it sounds like Tony has some
weapons and strategies ready to take on
thinness we've already seen some of his
new weapon upgrades to his suit in some
of the TV spots and trailers so it'll be
interesting to see how they hold up
against Thanos and Avengers end game
well that's it for this new TV spot let
me know what you think about it in the
comments down below and again if you
would like to enter my giveaway for a
chance to win a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet and a glow-in-the-dark painting
of Thanos by Globe I bow you can also
check out some of his other work at
globe by beau comm I'll put the link in
the description down below but all you
have to do to enter for your chance to
win to subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby